more vaccination sites popping up across
the valley
as the convention center also continues
those drive-through vaccines
but as victoria saha found a new clinic
that's in henderson comes
with a couple of different incentives
victoria
brian the las vegas convention center
has been a prime location
for the vaccine hubs and currently doing
drive-through vaccines tuesday through
saturday but there are other locations
to make it as convenient
as possible day one of the vaccine
clinic at galleria at sunset was off to
a steady start
people are out here shopping at the
malls or walking through we want to
attract them into this location give
them the opportunity
the clinic will be operating here for
the next six weeks
a new approach to make it as easy as
possible for you to get vaccinated
just came in and i went through the
process it was super easy
and then it took like maybe 10 seconds
15 seconds
super easy and convenient for anyone who
may live in this area
i'd rather be covering free than laying
in the hospital worrying about it the
clinic is administering
pfizer you can get the first or second
dose here i believe that anybody that
walks into this location we're going to
be able to get them a vaccination
and to entice people to get vaccinated a
free goodie bag from the mall
it has some snacks and like little
things in it so it'll be nice to just
show people
that i get a little extra something
the vaccine clinic at the galleria is
tuesday through friday from 8
until 2 pm they do accept walk-ins and
here at the convention center
their drive-through vaccines are tuesday
through saturday 8 30 till 4 pm
reporting live from the convention
center victoria saha 8 news now